♪ (SOFT MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
CECILIA ALDARONDO:
Imagine you had a nightmare
where you had to relive
your adolescence.
My memories shine
almost like a diamond.
But not because I loved them.
♪ (MUSIC DEFLATES) ♪
Because I hate them.
♪ (UPBEAT MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
When I was a teenager,
I would imagine myself
falling in love...
I love him, I love him,
I love him, I love him...
...for all my crushes.
I was trying to be whatever
they wanted me to be.
I was always just acting.
DIRECTOR: Roll, please.
Oh. Hi, Joel.
JOEL: (OVER PHONE)
Uh, who's this?
ALDARONDO: Oh, um...
-DIRECTOR: Cut!
-(LAUGHS)
♪ (MUSIC DARKENS) ♪
ALDARONDO:
I think of these recreations
as like an emotional exorcism.
Are you lost?
I sit there.
Get out of her seat.
I am truly haunted
by these things.
And one of the things
that I can't get past
is why they still bother me.
♪ (UNSETTLING MUSIC PLAYING) ♪
The guy organizing
the reunion posted this.
"Dress: Winter Park."
This is like blood red,
"I'm gonna kill them all."
-Resentment red.
-(LAUGHING) Resentment red.
ALDARONDO: Oh, God.
A country club.
I just feel like
this is a huge mistake.
(GROANS)
(LAUGHING)
Don't make me go in there.
♪ (MUSIC BRIGHTENS) ♪
SPEAKER: I can understand
being traumatized.
But why you continue,
all these years later,
to allow them to have
all this power over you
blows my mind.
ALDARONDO: Why would I
remember this for 25 years
if I didn't know then
that it was that bad?
♪ (MUSIC CONTINUES) ♪
The paradox of going back is
to have to succumb, once again,
to that sense of yourself
as totally inconsequential.
So, why on earth
would I go back?